[Music]
good morning everyone my name is ross
hanson i work for extend corporation in
provo utah
and i'll be speaking today about the
topic of catalytic chemistry and ways to
improve
your laboratory operations to make you
greener cleaner and more profitable
before we start
one very big note
i'm going to introduce you to somebody
who's certainly going to interrupt my
presentation
that's woody the great dane and at some
point he's gonna stick his head in here
and get in the way
so bear with me
i'll do the best that i can
so
i'm a big fan of a guy named colin
powell if you know who he was he was a
general and secretary of state but he
actually made his reputation as a
teacher and a trainer in the us army he
was well known for that and one of his
key mantras was
tell him what you're going to tell him
then tell him and then tell him what you
told them
so what i'm going to tell you about
today is today's key learnings we can
use modern analytical tools
to do a better job of keeping our labs
greener and safer for our employees
and for our customers and for of course
our environment and customers do you
care about green chemistry it's easy to
go oh wait a minute my cannabis
customers are a bit stoners
they really don't care i assure you they
do and the way you know that they do
is that if you look at every vape
cartridge manufactured some are co2
extracts and some aren't and the co2
ones cost more because they're cleaner
and greener and people pay for that they
pay for the better cleaner product so
let's not forget that that's important
let's use first principles of science
and specifically of chromatography
to make better decisions
better accuracy and to get better lods
and loqs limits of detection and limits
of quantitation
and finally by having better data at the
point of need
rather than over in the laboratory
perhaps we can get better business
decisions more rapidly and i'll talk
about specifically how that can happen
in a few moments
but to start i want to start with some
basic principles i want to start with
something chromatographers call the van
diemeter equation and dr van diemter was
a guy
who applied
rate theory to the chromatography
evolution process of peaks coming out of
a capillary or regular bore
hplc column and gc columns it applies to
all crack capillary chromatography
what we can see here in this slide
is that if we plot plate height versus
flow rate it says in this chart we'll
talk more about that in a minute because
it's not really flow rate but it shows
that the maximum efficiency of our
columns of our science happens when we
work at the point where the curve
the parabolic blue curve that you see is
at its lowest point
the lower that number is the more
efficient your column is and i'll
explain why in a minute
but it's important that we get the most
efficiency out of our products whether
they're columns lcs whatever we're using
and the reason for that is the more
efficiently we operate the less money we
spend to get the results that we need to
make the business decisions that we need
a little bit more detail on the van
diemer curve and you'll notice that now
the x-axis is not labeled velocity it's
labeled mobile phase velocity
it turns out that the speed of the
mobile phase which of course is directly
related to
the flow but we calculate velocity
because that's the calculation the
number that gives us the correct answer
from the van dieser equation and gives
us the best answer for where we should
be working scientifically
so you can see if you look inside the
circle in the dotted line as i described
before that low point for plate height
is the most efficient place to work why
is that important well we'll talk about
that in a minute but think efficiency
not just up the column but of your
applications and of your operations and
we're going to talk a lot about how to
be better in every facet of your
operation
but let's talk about what those
operations are first i think before we
can do that we have to consider
what do cannibal cannabinoid scientists
look at
well we know that they look at plant
materials in the field they look at
incoming quality control and boy do i
have something to say about how you test
product that comes into you
because it's really important when you
buy in product and then formulate it or
extract it you have to know what you got
in process monitoring as we're
extracting as we're isolating as we're
purifying
are we being as clean and efficient as
we can be at getting the best product
for our customer
i happen to do a lot of business with
cure relief
and i've tested their products myself
and i can tell you that we get some
great results from purely i can't speak
to others i haven't tested them but i
have done the curly product
oh and i forgot to talk about formulated
product testing when we talk about
formulated product testing one of the
things that we always want to be sure is
that the product we're formulating
actually starting at the right point
we know the cannabis changes in its
environment over time
and so we want to pay attention to
how the changes occur where they occur
and how do we make sure that we still
get our formulation right as the plant
changes
one of the things we did to look at this
was we went to a greenhouse in utah it's
near our office as i said we're
headquartered in provo although i happen
to personally live in sarasota florida
and i have a funny story about that in a
minute
but anyway living in
near utah or having our office near
there we were able to go over to the
greenhouse and do something you've
probably never seen before
and since you can see my camera i'm
going to show you something to look at
and that's an hplc that you can actually
carry around with you it's an lc with a
handle
pretty cool stuff
why is that important because it turns
out that sometimes you don't want to
bring the sample into the laboratory you
want to bring the laboratory out to the
sample
here's a fast cannabinoid profile
it took about six minutes and you can
see that what we got in that six minutes
is a profile of a half a dozen compounds
we could do more we could do less this
is very adaptable
to your specific need and you can adapt
these methods by customer so you can
actually assign a method to a customer
if you're a contract laboratory
and they're sending you a sample and
they want to know five cannabinoids
wouldn't it be nice to have a method
that belongs to customer xyz
and you get him his cannabinoids exactly
the way he wants them
i would point out to you something very
important about this chromatogram
if you look at the peaks between
three and four minutes you'll notice
that there's three peaks inside of a
half a minute and they're all pretty
close to baseline result they all have
resolution factors greater than one
when you look at that
why is it important it's because we're
getting three peaks out
in less than 30 seconds or in other
words each peak is less than 10 seconds
wide
why can we do that we can do that
because of what the slides along the
side or the data along the side of my
slide tells you which is that these are
columns that are 0.15
millimeters in diameter
0.15 millimeters most of you are almost
certainly using somewhere between two
and four millimeter columns a few brave
souls may be using one millimeter
columns but you're not using 0.1
millimeter columns
why is that important it lets us work
at a flow rate of one to two
microliters not milliliters per minute
and maintain if we go back to that
vandeeper curve we can stay in the most
critical part of the curve and get our
best results
while still
maintaining very low flows and as you
can see getting beautiful separations
the point that i'm making here is you're
using less solvent so it's costing you
less money and it's exposing your
scientists
to less
overall toxic waste
equally importantly when you buy a
milliliter of solvent whatever the
solvent is for hplc whatever you spend
to buy it you have to spend about the
same amount to get rid of it again it's
hazardous waste and it has to be
disposed of
that gives you the opportunity here to
cut not just your solvent costs
but yours your waste disposal cost
significantly and we'll talk about the
business of the laboratory in a minute
but right now let's focus on the science
when we come down to our next slide you
can see
equally great peaks you can see that
they are mostly baseline resolved
and equally importantly you can see that
these peaks
are sharp easily quantified and they
give you the best possible answer you
can get
now i'm going to go on to one more slide
about chromatograms
and here's why it's so important to make
a measurement
as close as possible to when you need
the right answer you look at this hemp
extract you'll notice that it's all cbda
cbga and cb
thca
there's almost none of cbg cbd or thc
why is that well they were probably
stored in a way that allowed the acid to
form rather than keep it in
the other form the thc the cbd the cbg
we can monitor that so when you go to
formulate a product you know hey wait a
minute this is the carboxylic carboxylic
acids we don't want that in our product
we really want the cbg and the cbd we
can convert that we we know how to
convert that with heat with whatever so
we can make a better decision before we
begin processing before we begin
delivering the goods if you will
one of the questions though and by the
way i'll note if you look at the uh
first peak the cbda peak look at how
sharp it is
i assure you if you go in your
laboratory and look at your
chromatography you can't do that
you can't do that
why is that important
every day we're learning that there are
more compounds in the overall profile of
cannabis and hemp that are either
medically or commercially or
recreationally important
they enhance the customer experience the
more peach you can jam in there the more
you can weigh so if you have big fat
peaks
you can't get as many analytes in a
given analysis as you can if you have
narrower sharper peaks we can do more
faster cheaper so i encourage you again
this is about capillary chromatography
not specifically our instrument or
anybody else's this is about using the
modern scientific tools to enhance
your results
but how good is the data i've never done
capillary chromatography you say i
understand it's a real pain in the neck
and we'll talk about that in a minute
but
how good is the data well i encourage
you to look at this chart and you can
see
three nines something all the way
through where we've detected a p and you
can see that we've got linear ranges of
three orders of magnitude or better so
you can work across a broad range
you can get incredibly precise and
accurate results
all of which will translate to a better
experience for your scientists a better
experience for your business people and
a better experience for your customers
but you know at the end of the day we
all have to make a living there's very
few people that work
altruistically we have to make a profit
in our companies the reason we companies
exist primarily except for nonprofits is
to make a profit
so let's talk about managing the assets
wisely
at work
let's make sure that the assets that we
have we're conserving and applying as
well as possible wasted money reduces
profits frankly it reduces your boss's
opportunity to give you a raise
it reduces opportunities for new markets
in business because when you're spending
money on solvent and waste disposal
you're not spending it on marketing
you're not spending it on
investing in new markets you're not
spending it on investing in the
education of your people or enhancing
your facilities you're just
creating waste and burning waste it's
better not to do that and i want to
encourage you to not think about money
as money
money isn't really what we often talk
about when we talk about
creating value
we can create time is money lost work
days are money energy costs are money
wastage is money
creating waste
is money
so as we consider what are the ways that
we might look at this paradigm of i want
really great results
but i don't want to spend more money to
get it what if you could spend less
money and get better results
what if
you could save the entire cost of the
instrument just based on switching to
capillary
here's some operational savings and we
took these i want you to ignore the
actual dollar values we used
and look at the ratio when you're
running an hplc with a 4.6 millimeter
column
versus 150 micron column there's a huge
difference in what it costs you to run
the instrument
in our case we just took the list price
for fisher scientific we know nobody
pays the list we get that
what we did is we took that number and
about a hundred dollar a liter for waste
disposal we didn't know if that was the
right number we heard that anecdotally
from a couple of labs but again it
doesn't matter it's the ratios whether
you're spending 10 000 or thirty
thousand dollars on this you're spending
a lot of money
we can cut that money by a factor look
at the factor two hundred and fifty
dollars instead of thirty two thousand
dollars in this calculation you are
throwing money out the door
you're just throwing it away
you shouldn't be doing that common sense
says let's do something smart
what does smarter look like
oh wait a minute i didn't even talk
about the cost of actually running the
instrument
one of the changes that you can make in
your instruments is to substitute light
emitting diodes in many cases we have
them in our homes now we call them leds
and they're in our kitchens our ceilings
everywhere why not use those specific
wavelength leds to lower the energy cost
of running our instrument
not only don't we have to make the pumps
pump much higher volumes of solvent at
high pressure which costs money but we
can lower the amount of money you spend
on lamps
immediately
a diode as you know typically lasts
about 20 000 hours
a comparable deuterium lamp lasts about
2 000 hours so you can improve your
performance by a lot we calculated using
the acs
amgs green chemistry score
and we calculated the energy costs i
live in florida so i took the cost in
florida of 0.13
dollars per kilowatt hour and you can
see that you save again
an enormous amount of money eighty
percent of your energy costs go down
when you're using hplc that's capillary
instead of using hplc that's normal bore
we can save you money and i want to give
credit these calculations did not come
from me
i'm working with a scientist at merc
named mike hicks my kicks did these
calculations i'm just reporting his data
so i want to give credit to those guys
and i want to bring up another point
you'll notice that i mentioned
pharmaceutical companies
i do a lot of work with pharma i have
throughout my 30 or 40 year career i
want to tell you that
cannabis is headed for the paradigm that
is pharma
today it's not quite in the pharma mold
but it will be we're making
substances that people eat that they
drink that they ingest somehow either
for a health benefit or a recreational
benefit
and we need to know that we're not
hurting anybody ultimately we can expect
the entire cannabis party to move under
the tent of the fda
it's probably ten years from now when
the fda finally wakes up and goes yeah
okay cannabis is really a medicine but
at some point that's gonna happen and we
should prepare for that as soon as
possible
a lot of what i'm talking to you about
today are ideas that the pharma
community has long since embraced
bringing the lab to the sample
bringing the instrument right next to
where you need it those kinds of things
the instrument i showed you which is our
product at xn was designed with the
pharmaceutical market in place not with
the cannabis market but since cannabis
is a subset of pharma it works very
nicely
one last thing i want to talk about when
we talk about employee health and safety
i wonder how many of you ever thought of
what acetonitrile really is
did you ever look at the formula well i
got a hint for you it's methyl cyanide
when you use a four liter jug a gallon
of
acetonitrile you're exposing your
employees to methyl cyanide that's
cuckoo puffs
we want to limit that as much as we can
why wouldn't you want small vials
instead of large jugs of
carcinogens and i will show you if you
look at the picture on the right those
three vials that are in the front of
that hplc and that is an hplc in spite
of its size it's a 10 000 psi hplc that
has a handle
those three vials hold solvent a solvent
b and waste enough to run for an entire
week they're nine milliliter vitals
an entire week on nine milliliters
doesn't that make sense to your lab
doesn't that make sense to your
employees doesn't that make sense to
your company
i think it does and by the way when we
go to smaller instruments we can also
start to put them in safer places like
hoods and glove boxes when they're using
solvents that aren't safe for the
employees
how rugged is it
we know 25 years ago when capillary came
out i was in sales at agilent at the
time and i'll tell you what
nobody wanted to do capillary the
columns weren't that great to be honest
the
ruggedness of the instruments wasn't
that great it's 20 years later it's like
if you bought the first electric car
10 years ago versus what they are today
or what they'll be in another 10 years
it's clear that this is the trend of the
industry we're not going to keep
allowing hplcs
to generate a liter of waste every 24
hours and then have to pollute the
environment burning it that's gonna
change we should begin to change before
we're forced to change
so where can you use capillary
instrumentation where is it already
being used
all of these places you see
if you email me i will send you papers
from every one of these industries where
work is being done on capillary columns
they work great you have to filter your
samples that's the one thing filter your
samples but other than that capillary
columns work
pretty much like everything else
and i want to give a shout out to a
company some of you may be familiar with
it's restek in uh belfast pennsylvania
if you're wondering how do i convert my
regular methods to capillary methods go
to restek.com and on their website they
have the easy method lc calculator you
put in your your normal conditions you
tell it what column and solvent system
you're going to switch to
and it does the calculation and it gets
you within about 80
of your method conversion
i encourage you to use that every time
somebody comes to me and says i've got
this i want to convert it
i'm way past doing that math in my head
why not use the tools we've been given
and i encourage you to use the restek
calculator it's funny restek doesn't
sell capillary columns but they have the
lc calculator i think that's great
and last but not least as i promised you
i was going to tell you what i was going
to tell you
and then i was going to tell you well
now i'm going to tell you what i just
told you
analytical tools are available to make
your labs better
safer more efficient and more cost
effective
and our customers really do care about
it
i can assure you that when a company
like merc pharmaceutical
is calculating green scores for their
instruments
the world is taking us seriously and we
need to take that seriously
first principles of chromatography which
have been around for years and years and
years we didn't make up new science we
just took the science and applied it to
a better way to do it
and finally by having an instrument that
you can take anywhere you want it to go
it can bring the instrument to your
point of need so a hempfield a cannabis
grow house whatever it is a formulation
station where you're blending product
that you bought it in your formulating
that can all be combined
in a capillary format
i want to thank you all so much
and
i wish you all good analysis
thank you
you